that would be a little hard to say but
when I was 8 years old my grandfather
died and I knew that he had written
poetry because I used to see him writing
poetry in his books and I was very close
to him and after he died I went down to
the basement of my family house where my
family kept books anthologies and things
and there was an anthology without any
names attached to and I read a poem
called spellbound and I somehow attached
it to my grandfather's death and I I
thought my grandfather had written it in
fact I was sure he had written it and it
was a great consolation to me and
something planted in my mind that you
could write poetry that you could read
poetry the poetry could somehow console
you I didn't sit down then and start
writing poems but it was in the back of
my mind now when I was in high school I
was leafing through an anthology that
our teachers had given us and I found it
a poem I go this is so strange this this
poem looks so much like my grandfather's
poem when I lit her another one
grandpa's poem it turns out I'd been
written by Emily brontë and it wasn't my
grandfather's poem at all although my
response to it I think was pretty much
the same I just had the author wrong but
that was the beginning though I didn't
start writing till I was in high school
and when I was in high school I really
began to I really began to write poetry
with great energy and enthusiasm
to show them to my sister and I thought
everything I wrote was so great
my poor sister who's a year younger than
I am couldn't understand them at a wall
but she was enthusiastic about my
writing them when I was a freshman in
college I went to Grinnell College in
Iowa
I brought my poems to my freshmen you
manatees teacher whose name was Carol
parson and a wonderful teacher and Carol
did a really great thing for me she's
she taught me more than anyone she
somehow read my poems and came back to
me and convinced me that I could be a
poet that I had the passion and the
enthusiasm and the creativity to become
a poet but that what I was writing was
not poetry because I was just expressing
my feelings and I wasn't trying to make
anything the oldest word for for poetry
in Greek is poesis which means making a
poet as a maker and a poem as a made
thing and Carol somehow convinced me
that I could become a poet but that I
was not writing poetry and then I would
have to try and make something to write
poetry and that I started then to try
and shape something rather than just
express it and when I started to shape
something and to imitate other poems
that were written by other people when I
tried to integrate my reading and my
writing I was on my path I guess that
would have been 1968 I was a freshman in
college and I I wasn't writing good
poems but I was at least trying to write
poems then
there's been no poet no great poet in
the history of poetry who hasn't also
been a great reader of poetry this is
sometimes distressing to my students
when I tell them this now I do say it's
possible you might be the first I'm not
saying it's impossible but the odds are
very much against you all great poets
have been great readers and the way to
learn your craft in poetry is by reading
other poetry and by letting it guide you
a great model for this is the way that
Dante calls on Virgil at the beginning
of the inferno the Divine Comedy to help
guide him through the underworld and in
a way that's also a recognition that
Dante needs Virgil and that the unfair
inferno needs the Aeneid and that the
epic needs a model and that for Dante to
write this great poem he needs someone
to come before him and he turns to
Virgil's text especially book six where
Aeneas goes down into the underworld and
for me that's a model of the poet's
relationship to a pre to previous poetry
to another poetry as as calling out for
guidance
there are many poets that I use as my
models in my first book of poems
I had several for The sleepwalkers I had
several poems that were apprentice poems
like this in which I take a walk with it
with it with a poet who's no longer
alive one of them as I walk with
Federico Garcia Lorca around the Upper
West Side in Manhattan because that was
a neighborhood he lived in and I imagine
walking around Paris with Cesar Vallejo
great Peruvian poet who lived in Paris
and I kind of like the walk as a kind of
drama of my apprenticeship now it is
true that I think one of the things that
distinguished my work from the beginning
when I was in college was my turning
towards poetry from other countries that
I didn't ever consider poetry the
province exclusively of English and
American literature and I discovered a
great amount in reading polish poetry
and other Eastern European poetry and
reading Russian poetry and reading Latin
American and Spanish poetry and I've
always found models in those other
poetry's of poets who could help me on
my path
very deep ways that you don't entirely
understand Rainer Maria Rilke said there
are two inexhaustible sources for poetry
one is dreams and the other is childhood
and I think childhood is an
inexhaustible source of your becoming
who you will be and certain deep
feelings are set inside of you a certain
construct of emotions that really define
who you are and who you will become
and I feel very much that my childhood
is very alive inside of me very close to
me very much part of me and it's an in
sometimes painful sometimes joyous
inexhaustible resource for poetry and a
lot of poor trees putting yourself back
into the state of wonder that you have
before things when you're a child it's
not only a joyous wonder it's sometimes
a grief-stricken wonder I have the idea
that lyric poetry is a poetry that's
driven by a sense of the presence of
death that there's something unbearable
about the fact that we're going to die
and that we can't stand it and I think
you find that out in childhood and you
don't really at least I found it out in
childhood and I found it hard to get
over and now I'm 60 years old and I
still find it hard to get over and I
think it's one of the things that drive
lyric poetry our sense of mortality our
sense that things are transient that
everything is passing and that if you
want to save something from the endless
flux of experience in the world's
movement you have to set down a stake
and try and make something that will
last
I think it's changed over time I mean
when I was young I could write all
through the night and I loved to work
late into the night now that I'm older I
work really well in the early morning
when your synapses are firing a little
better but I work at different times
today I don't have a set schedule to
work on poetry at any given time at the
same time every day but I true to try to
work on poetry every day and I true to
do find some time every day that I can
and with some exceptions
to work on poetry but the best times I
have found in my life are late at night
or early in the morning and I think it's
because you're outside the social realm
you're alone with yourself and your own
feelings and that gives you deeper
access to what you need to get in touch
with to write poetry now the process of
writing poetry is very messy not
systematic never quite the same
sometimes I have a feeling that I just
can't get rid of sometimes there's an
experience that I want to write about
that I that I have to get off my did I
have to get off my chest
sometimes there are some words that
appeal to you often you've read another
poem that you think is so beautiful that
you'd like to make something like that
and so you try to make a sonnet that
works in a certain kind of way or you
try to make something that's so unlike
or you create a refrain or you love the
way a poem works in two line stanzas and
you try to do that and what I've found
over time is that for me to write a poem
that I think is worthy that I can live
with two things have to happen one
something emotional has to be at stake
there has to be something important for
me that I'm writing about and then two I
have to have a formal idea something has
to be being worked out in poetry you
know that can be a traditional form form
or can be something you're inventing it
can be the development of a metaphor the
working through of a metaphor but
something has to be worked through
formally as well as emotionally now when
those two things come together I've got
something I think that that I can be
proud of
sometimes the title comes
the beginning sometimes it comes at the
end the very best way in my experience
is when it comes in the middle that you
write a phrase or you think of something
and it seems to have a deeper charge
because the the title has to be some
kind of marker some kind of something
setting out a space creating a space for
what's gonna come and my experience is
the best titles for me emerge in the
process of writing they don't usually
come at the very beginning and hopefully
they don't come at the very end because
then it's getting late in the day now
sometimes I change the title
I was surprised recently to find a book
called poetry in persons that's coming
out about visits of poets to a class
that pearl London gave and when my
second book had come out while gratitude
I went to pearl London's class and she
worked through different drafts of poems
and there were the drafts of my poem
while gratitude and I saw that I had
begun the poem with the title August
13th and it was the title August 13th
for most of the way and then near the
end sometime in the process I got the
idea that maybe that would be a somewhat
bland title and I got the idea for a
wild gratitude which I'm very proud of
as a title so I think it works best when
you find it in the process
there are things that poets in the
history poetry hit upon when they're
very young that can never be outdone and
it's a remarkable strange experience
when you think of say Arthur Rimbaud who
wrote poetry between the ages of 17 and
21 whose career was over by the time he
was 22 or John Keats who notoriously
died in this in his 20s and yet had you
know packed a wealth of experience into
his poems before then I think there is a
poetry the Hebrew scholar scholars of
the Hebrew Bible to find something they
call wisdom literature and I would say
clearly the poetry of wisdom is
something that comes with age or that
might come with age that which is has to
do with reflecting on experience and a
certain kind of poetry looks back at
experience from an older perspective
it's hard to think that say Shakespeare
could have written the tempest when he
was young it's it seems to be a
reflective work or retrospective work at
the same time there's the brilliant
audacity of youth that poets strike upon
in their earliest work sometimes that
they never can hit upon again and
sometimes you look at the first poems by
someone and you go they have a freshness
and a sense of wonder that has never
recaptured again by that poet so I think
there are different kinds of of poetry
for different stages of life and there's
the wild exuberance of youth there's the
painful
agon of midlife experience there's the
late poetry in the presence of death and
I think you're what you hope for is that
at different times of your life you're
able to write the poetry that that
reflects the moment that you're in in
your own on your own journey
I was once doing a question and answer
period with the novelist Jane smiley in
a bookstore and someone asked us what
our processes were and Jane said hers
and then I said mine and Jane said well
if I had a student like that I'd force
him never to write like that again
because you could never write a novel in
the way that you write poetry which is I
don't shout drafts and then revise them
but I don't what I do was I team team to
revise as I go and so I write a line and
then I revise the line and then I write
two lines and then I revise lines one
and two and then I write one two and
three and I revise one and two and then
I write seven and eight and then I see
that should be line four and I
continually work it over as I go so it's
a continual process of trial and error
and then I find things and I throw it
out and start again but I keep writing
it over again so the result though is by
the time I've got something it's been
worked over so many times that although
I do make changes at the end often by
the time I've gotten it it's pretty much
completed now that can take two days it
can take three weeks it can take four
months depending on how the process is
going now as I've gotten older I've been
able to write more quickly sometimes I
get in the space of something and I can
do a lot in a day the mysterious thing
about writing poetry is that when you
are when things are going poorly when
you're not thinking well even making two
sentences together is extremely hard and
I just can't make the connections and
when I'm writing well and when I'm
inside the feeling then I can do fairly
complicated things with some fluency so
some of the most difficult formal poems
that I've written say one sentence
sonnets in territory ma I've been able
to do those fairly quickly whereas some
of the clearest simplest lyrics that
I've written have taken me the longest
to get to the clarity of feeling
you're looking for so the process of
revision it's not systematic but for me
I mean I know a lot of poets who write
out a draft and then revise it and I
think they're happier people but I'm
just not able to do it that way I need
to just continually examine it as I do
it
the attention deficit disorder of the
culture is very distressing in America
now and I think it puts a lot of things
at risk not just poetry there's never
been a culture without poetry in the
history of the world in every culture in
every language there's expressive play
expressed expressive word play there's
language used to different purposes that
we would call poetry so I think poetry
will survive and I don't think it will
be the end of poetry our tremendous the
tremendous onslaught of mass media all
the time that we're suffering and we
don't really know how to think about
I think that puts certain things at risk
I don't think poetry will died but I
think that poetry does demand a certain
kind of attention to language it does
demand a certain space in order to read
it and I think that space is somewhat
threatened by the lack of attention that
people have in the amount of time that
they give to things so I just think that
that limits the kinds of experiences
that people can have with poetry but
poetry will survive I don't I don't
worry about that but I do think that it
may save a few fewer souls if people
can't pay attention
I think they can do both things
depending on the poet I think that the
the dark side of MFA programs is that
they're generating more poets than the
culture can absorb and there are more
people writing poetry than possibly read
it or can certainly earn a living
around it and so that's that's a stress
on the system and I think a painful
thing for many young poets who are
looking to find a life in poetry that
they're not going to be able to find the
very good thing about MFA programs is
they're democratizing they bring a lot
of different people to the table it's
not I mean in the history of poetry
there have been a lot of porches where
you have to inherit the position of poet
from your ancestors and I think that if
you just leave anyone to become a poet
based on an aristocratic Society then a
lot of people are left out who might
have something to offer and I think the
MFA program is a way of bringing a lot
of different people to the table and
inviting them in so I think that's very
good I would be happier if people who
went through MFA programs also had were
already by then deeply committed readers
of poetry because we need readers of
poetry as much as writers of poetry and
I think in terms of educating a group of
readers MFA programs are very are very
good I just think the model of MFA
programs in which a young poet ghosted
program publishes a series of books gets
teaching jobs that's a that's a bit at
risk I don't think the culture can
absorb so many people writing poetry and
trying to earn their living in poetry
first of all I think that poetry is very
noble and I always have with me the
sense of the nobility of poetry and when
you are entering into poetry whatever
stage you're at you are participating in
something with a very long and noble
tradition and so I would keep in mind to
a young poet that you were entering
there's something that is very important
that has always been important in terms
of human concerns the way to become a
poet is to read poetry and to imitate
what you read and to read passionately
and widely and has involved the way as
you can it's not important it's not
necessary that you read everything what
is necessary is that you care about
things that you read and you find
something that really matters to you and
you try and make something like that and
I think that as long as you have other
poets before you and that you can learn
from them then it's always open-ended
for you there's always someplace to go
you don't need workshops you don't need
friends necessarily you can be
befriended by literature itself Emily
Dickinson calls previous poets her
kinsman of the Shelf you can always be
consoled by your kinsmen of the shell of
the Shelf and you can participate in
poetry by going to them and by trying to
make something worthy of them Gertrude
Stein said I write for myself and
strangers I would say I write for myself
strangers and the great dead
double-take magazine once printed a
little pamphlet on which I listed 10
different things that you should you
should do I can't remember all of them
but the first one was turn off the
television set I don't think you can you
can read poetry while you're watching
television very well the idea of how to
read a poem is based on the idea that
that poetry needs you as a reader that
the experience of poetry the meaning in
poetry is a kind of circuit that takes
place between a poet a poem and a reader
and that meaning doesn't exist or in
here and poems alone that readers bring
their own experiences their own range of
their own wisdom their own knowledge
their own insights to poems and the
meaning of a poem takes place in the
negotiation between the poet the poem
and the reader and that as a reader you
have a task to do you have something to
do you bring your experience to it it's
not all inherent in the poem the great
Holocaust post-holocaust poet Paul salon
said that a poem is a message in a
bottle sent out and the not always
greatly hopeful belief that somewhere
and sometime it would wash up on land on
heartland perhaps the idea of a poem is
a message in a bottle means that it's
sent out towards some future reader and
the reader who opens that bottle becomes
the addressee of the literary text salon
was picking up something that the
Russian poet OSA Mandelstam had written
in 1916 called on the addressee and
mondal stump says a poet you go down to
the shore and you see an unlikely
looking from a bottle from the past you
open it mondal stump says it's okay to
do so I'm not reading someone else's
mail it was addressed whoever found it I
found it
therefore it's addressed to me and that
when you find it you become the secret
address see of a literary text and I
felt that the reader had been left out
of this experience of reading poetry or
what right or what the experience of
poetry was and so my focus is on
the reader and that the poet's job is
not to inspire himself or herself the
poet's job is to inspire some future
reader and so as a reader you have a
task to do in finding those bottles and
opening up the messages and experiencing
what's in them inside of yourself
connection that you can only hope for
it's not something that you can make
because it to me you know it needs
someone else I find in in Walt Whitman
and an American tradition a certain kind
of I would say desperate American
friendliness in which you reach out in
which the poet tries to reach out
through the page to make a connection by
the side of the road with some other
person but ultimately that's that's a
longing not a completion that has to be
made by other readers you can't seek
clarity you can seek warmth you can try
to make something for lasting you can
Peck something in salt so that it's well
made and you can hope that it out last
time but ultimately that's not up to you
ultimately you're trying to reach across
and find some other person some other
human warmth but it is especially in
written poetry it is inscribed in a text
and the text can't do that work by
itself and you as a poet can only do
your best
when I taught at the University of
Houston in the Creative Writing Program
we required the poets to take workshops
in in fiction writing and we acquired
the fiction writers to take workshops in
poetry and the reason for that is
because the fiction writers seemed to
need to learn how to pay greater
attention to language itself to the way
that laying which works the poet's
needed to learn to pay greater attention
to character and to narrative that as
many poets don't know how to tell a
story and they don't have a sense of how
to put things in order to tell a story
and we thought that poets could learn
from fiction writers something about
developing a character over time who
wasn't just you and also creating a
narrative structure so I think it's true
that that's something that poetry can go
to school on fiction poetry can go to
fiction to learn think that the the the
deepest thing is that many fiction
writers tell stories but are not elegant
writers but we're not writing journalism
when we're making literature we are
trying to make something that lasts in
language and there's no question that
many fiction writers began as poets and
it's hard for me to think of any good
fiction writers who don't also read
poetry that fiction writers learn about
the development of metaphor the the use
of rhythm the way that language is
compacted in order to express that the
feelings that express their own feelings
and the feelings of their characters so
I think fiction goes to poetry for the
intensity of its use of language
when I was young I did and in fact when
I was young I wrote everything and I
thought I would be an all-round writer
that I would write everything when I was
in my early 20s I still had that idea
and I wrote an unpublished novel and I
wrote a lot of short stories but what I
discovered about myself is that my
temperament is so fiery in terms of what
I like in literature that I like so much
intensity that too much was happening
all the time it was it was just like
starting with too much adrenaline and
you stated it and then adrenaline rush
all the time it turns out that doesn't
work for fiction fiction has to take
novel takes place over time it's a
historical narrative and it needs to
have a series of peaks and valleys and
to move through the well you can't just
start at the highest pitch and stay
there but you can Italy in a lyric poem
and so I found my temperament is very
much drawn to the lyric poetry and for
the compression of lyric poetry so it
seems that I have the the temperament of
a poet not entirely of a fiction writer
there's a debate in the whole history of
poetry between the plain style and the
golden hour aureate style and the poetry
is continually in some kind of
relationship between these two pulls
something more Baroque in ornate
something more ornamental and something
more plain spoken something simpler and
I feel the tugs of those two traditions
in say the 17th century or in Spanish
baroque poetry or the work of John Donne
who I admire very much and so what I
would say is I myself have a especially
as I've gotten older I longed for
clarity and I longed for the the pure
clear word but by the drive but by the
drive of the feeling and the intensity
of the expression and the thing you're
trying to express and make you hope that
the words have wings that is you're
looking for something that will lift
them off now how to get that lift off no
one knows exactly and there's no recipe
for it if there was everyone would be
writing great poems ever want to be
going to school with Emily Dickinson and
writing those you know remarkable lyrics
of hers or writing Shakespeare sonnets
but what you're looking for
is a kind of clear language that gets a
kind get that gets a depth charge that
lifts it and gives it wings so you hear
the phrase brightness falls from the air
and you know you're in the presence of
poetry that something has happened to
the language the words themselves
brightness falls from the air are all
very clear and very simple but when they
come together in this particular way
they've got a radiance and a beauty that
stands all alone and I think that what
is that the observation of light the
clarity of the feeling the sense of
wonder
words give you no one knows exactly but
you're seeking in this combination of
words to find something new and fresh
that will strike a deeply resonant chord
so that when we read Sappho now it's as
powerful to us as when it was written in
lesbos so many centuries ago
this is the title poem
my book special orders give me back my
father walking the halls of Wertheimer
box and paper company with sawdust
clinging to his shoes give me back his
tape measure and his keys his drafting
pencil in his order forms
give me his daydreams online paper I
don't understand this uncontrollable
grief whatever you had that never fit
whatever else you needed believe me my
father who wanted your business would
squat down at your side and sketch you a
container for it
well the first thing you'd like to be
remembered for are for your poems and
I've spent my life in poetry and I'd
like my poems to last and I'd like to
remember it for my poetry and in terms
of my legacy I think everything radiates
from that and so first of all you'd like
to remember it as a poet and a poet who
tried to bring the deepest feeling to
poetry and I'd like to remember it as a
passionate poet who kept what John Keats
calls the holiness of the hearts
affections secondarily I'd like to be
remembered for my advocacy for poetry
and my trying to defend poetry in a time
when poetry was at risk and there have
always been great defenses of poetry and
I've tried to write mine and I think all
of my work in criticism is a defence of
poetry to try and keep something alive
in poetry and then as a teacher of
poetry I'd like that to be I think the
teaching of poetry is part of that
legacy of trying to carry on the
tradition of poetry everywhere in the
world and keeping it going and then
lastly I think this is spilled over into
my work in trying to support the arts
not just poetry but all of literature
and all of the arts through the
Guggenheim Foundation so that we're
trying to keep something alive in the
culture we're trying to keep seeing
something going that we don't want to
die that seems important and so I'd like
to remember for that work too
you have a lot of worries but you're
trying to I don't know I think there's
the things that keep me up aside from
personal things which can always you
know can always get you and keep you up
in terms of your personal life are you
doing your best is this the best work
you can do
you're shadowed by you know you're your
own dream especially as you get older of
trying to create something that will
last in poetry and so you're working on
its behalf
now sometimes I'm awake at night
brooding about a particular poem
sometimes I'm awake with something less
noble in terms of what happened what
happened in the day or in the days one
of the gratifying things for me about
this is I've always written about
insomnia and insomnia has been one of my
subjects from the time I was in my 20s
because I've never been a very restful
sleeper and I like the metaphor of
insomnia and poetry that is someone
who's awake in the middle of the night
is a soul consciousness when everyone
else is asleep and that creates a
feeling of solitude in poetry that I
very much like so sometimes when I'm
awake one when I was younger I would
just write right then but now I just
remember the feeling and think I can
make something out of this out of this
sense of isolation or loneliness or
desolation if you get in 4:00 a.m.